From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And I am happy to welcome to the studio Lilly Sullivan, one of our producers. Hey, Lilly.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。很高兴欢迎我们的制片人之一莉莉·沙利文来到演播室。你好，莉莉。
Hi, Ira.
你好，艾拉。
And you're here because we wanted to kick off today's show with this interview that you did. And explain who this is with.
你今天来到这里，是因为我们想用你做的这个采访来开启今天的节目。介绍一下采访对象是谁吧。
So, this interview is with this guy named Jackson Landers. Jackson, he's an outdoorsy type of person. He fishes, he hunts. And he writes about that stuff. He's a journalist who sometimes does this adventure journalism. Like, he wrote a whole book where he traveled around North America, hunting and eating invasive species. But the thing that I talked to him about was this one moment that happened near his house in Virginia. This day, he went fishing.
这次采访的对象是一个叫杰克逊·兰德斯的人。杰克逊是个户外运动爱好者。他会钓鱼、打猎，还撰写关于这些题材的文章。他是一位偶尔从事探险新闻报道的记者。比如，他曾写过一整本书，讲述他在北美各地旅行，猎捕并食用入侵物种的故事。但我跟他谈论的是发生在他弗吉尼亚州家附近的一件事。那天，他去钓鱼。
And I got in my car. I already had the fishing gear in the car. It stays there all summer. And went to the reservoir, and I pick up my water shoes, and I put them on. And while I'm putting one of them on, I feel like a-- it's like a bee sting. And it didn't last long. It wasn't too painful, but it felt like a bee sting. I took off the shoe, and I shook it out. And I saw the pieces of the dead spider, and I knew those are the legs and the fragments of a dead black widow. Oh, boy. This isn't good.
我上了车，车里一直放着渔具，整个夏天都没拿出来。我开车去了水库，穿上涉水鞋。就在我穿鞋的时候，感觉像是——像被蜜蜂蜇了一下。没持续多久，也不算太疼，但确实感觉像被蜜蜂蜇了。我脱下鞋，抖了抖，看到了一只死蜘蛛的残骸，我认出那是黑寡妇蜘蛛的腿和身体碎片。糟了，这可不妙。
So Jackson actually knows a lot about black widow spiders and their bites. He lives in a place where there are a lot of them. And sometimes he finds them in the house. Or one time, he found one, and he put it in a Mason jar and kept that jar in his desk for months. And he would feed it and observe it and watch its behavior.
杰克逊其实对黑寡妇蜘蛛和它们的叮咬非常了解。他住的地方有很多这种蜘蛛，有时他在家里也能发现它们。有一次，他抓到一只，把它放进玻璃罐里，在书桌上养了几个月。他会喂它东西吃，观察它的习性。
So he knew a lot about them, and he also knew that the truth is, black widow bites are very rarely fatal. They're just really painful, the kind of pain that would leave someone doubled over, incapacitated. But Jackson, he'd just been bit, and he's not feeling any of that yet.
所以他很了解它们，也知道事实上黑寡妇咬人很少致命。它们只会带来剧痛，那种让人蜷缩、失去行动能力的疼痛。但杰克逊刚被咬，此时还没感觉到这些。
It was just, it felt like a bee sting. And I thought, well, OK, is this really what I think it is? Or-- I don't know-- maybe this isn't that bad. And while I was thinking about it, I picked up my cast net. I was fishing with a net. And I went down to the water's edge, and I started fishing.
当时的感觉就像被蜜蜂蜇了一下。我想，好吧，这真的是我以为的那样吗？或者——我不确定——也许没那么严重。就在我思考的时候，我拿起了撒网。我正用网捕鱼。我走到水边，开始钓鱼。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
So I'm fishing while I'm mulling this over.
所以我一边琢磨这件事，一边钓鱼。
Wait, so you started fishing?
等等，所以你就开始钓鱼了？
Yeah, I mean, I'm there. There's the water, there's the net. And in retrospect, this was absolutely irrational. And I knew that, yes, you have to seek medical attention. And by the way, as I recall, I don't think I had health insurance at the time. So part of it is like, I don't want to incur medical bills if I don't have to, if I can just tough this thing out and just be in pain.
是啊，毕竟我都在那儿了。水在那儿，网也在那儿。回想起来，这绝对是不理智的。我当时也知道，是的，你应该去寻求医疗救助。顺便说一下，我记得当时我好像没有医疗保险。所以部分原因是我不想花不必要的医疗费，如果我能忍过去，能承受这种痛苦的话。
He also knew that when you go to the hospital, they almost never give you the antivenom.
他也知道，当你去医院时，他们几乎从不给你注射抗毒血清。
That's the stuff that can cure a black widow bite.
那就是能治疗黑寡妇咬伤的特效药。
Mm-hm. Because there's a fear that while the black widow bite probably won't kill you, the antivenom actually might. So when you go to the hospital, they usually just help you manage your symptoms.
嗯。因为人们担心虽然黑寡妇咬伤可能不会要了你的命，但抗毒血清却可能导致危险。所以你去医院时，他们通常只是帮你缓解症状。
And so I knew that if I went to the hospital, it would probably just be maybe to give you some pain medication. You're just going to be in a lot of pain for like three days. And they're just providing nursing care. And part of me was thinking, maybe I'll just do that at home for free.
所以我知道如果我去医院，可能也就只能打点止痛药。你得忍受三天的剧痛。他们只是提供基础护理。所以当时我想，也许我可以免费在家里处理这件事。
He didn't go home, though. He just continued doing what he was doing.
但他没有回家，而是继续做他正在做的事。
Fishing.
钓鱼。
Yeah, and then he started to feel this tightness in his stomach.
是的，然后他开始感到胃部一阵紧缩。
And it didn't hurt at first. It was just tightness. And then it grew and grew to where it feels like I was being like punched in the stomach, that, OK, this is bad. I got to get out of here. Home is 10 minutes away. I drove home, and I laid down on the floor. And I thought, OK, I can do this.
起初并不疼，只是紧绷感。接着它越来越严重，就像被人对着胃部猛击一样，心想，好吧，这下严重了。我得离开这儿。家就在10分钟路程外。我开车回家，躺在地上。我想，好吧，我可以挺过去。
And I posted on Facebook, just so people would know, if nobody hears from me for a while, this is the situation. [LAUGHS] I'm at home. I'm laying on the floor. And if nobody hears from me, this is what's happening. I'm laying on the floor. I got bit by a black widow.
我在Facebook上发了条状态，只是想让人们知道，如果一段时间没人收到我的消息，这就是情况。[笑声]我在家里，躺在地上。如果没人联系我，情况就是这样。我被黑寡妇咬了。
And then it got bad enough, the punch in the stomach got tighter and tighter. And it got bad enough, I thought, I'm not going to be able to deal with this. I need whatever pain medication they're going to give me at the hospital. I can't take this anymore. It was started to feel like imagine your entire chest is in a vise. Like, imagine a medieval torture device that's just going to crush your chest, where it's somebody who's turning a screw, a little bit more and a little bit more.
然后情况变糟了，胃部的重击感越来越紧。严重到我觉得自己快扛不住了。我需要去医院，管他们给什么止痛药都行。我受不了了。感觉就像你的整个胸腔被虎钳夹住一样。想象一下中世纪的刑具，正在慢慢挤压你的胸腔，有人在一点点拧紧螺丝，一次又一次。
Jackson's mom drives him to the hospital. And when he gets there, it's really lucky for him because they have a new experimental antivenom that they give him.
杰克逊的妈妈开车送他去了医院。他很幸运，因为医院里有一种他们刚给他的实验性新型抗毒血清。
And it was like this wave of wonderfulness I felt pass through my body from the point where the IV went. I could feel a wave of pain just being erased--
我感觉到一股奇妙的力量从静脉注射点传遍全身。我能感觉到那股剧痛正在消退——
Wow.
哇。
--as it just moved through my arm and then into my chest and throughout my whole torso and then down through my legs into my feet. It was like I could feel the venom being erased somehow.
——它顺着我的手臂移动，进入胸部，流向整个躯干，然后顺着双腿一直到脚底。那种感觉就像我能感觉到毒液以某种方式被清除了。
So it worked.
所以奏效了。
Yeah. But the fact that he waited so long to stop fishing and get to a hospital, he's thought a lot about that decision. He says it wasn't just about the money. It's mostly something else.
是的。但他为决定何时停止钓鱼去医院所花费的漫长时间，让他对这个决定深思熟虑。他说这不仅仅是钱的问题。更多是因为其他原因。
One of the things that prevented me from making a decision more quickly when I was bit was a failure to accept a radically new reality that most of me feels fine right after I was bit. It felt like a bee sting. And the sun was still shining, and everything looks and feels the same.
被咬后，阻碍我迅速做出决定的一件事是，我无法接受一个全新的现实，因为被咬后大部分时间我感觉还好。那感觉就像被蜜蜂蜇了一下。阳光依旧灿烂，一切看起来和感觉起来都没什么两样。
And when everything looks the same, it's very difficult to accept that reality has just changed, where things are about to be really different. And I could be in agonizing pain, and I need to go to a hospital. And things could become very expensive and very chaotic and very stressful. And it's very easy to just be sort of paralyzed by an unwillingness to accept that.
当一切看起来都一样时，你很难接受现实已经改变，事情即将变得截然不同。我可能陷入剧痛，我需要去医院，事情可能会变得非常昂贵、混乱且充满压力。那种不愿接受现实的心态很容易让人陷入瘫痪。
Well, today on our program, people who are in a situation where reality changes and they have not caught up to the new reality they're living in. This happens in so many different kinds of situations. We actually got the idea for this episode from something that a climate futurist said in an article about wildfires. The guy's name is Alex Steffen. And he talked about how so many of us, when it comes to the climate, are experiencing, quote, "the shock that comes with recognizing that you are unprepared for what has already happened."
今天在我们的节目中，我们要谈论那些身处现实发生改变，却还没赶上他们所处新现实的人。这种情况发生在各种各样的情况下。这一集的灵感其实来自于一位气候未来学家关于野火的文章。那个人叫亚历克斯·史蒂芬。他谈到，在我们面对气候问题时，许多人正在经历所谓的“意识到你对已经发生的事情毫无准备而带来的冲击”。
Haven't you felt that with climate? Maybe with where politics has gone in this country the last few years or with personal news, sometimes. The shock of realizing you're unprepared for what has already happened. Today, we hear stories of people struggling with that exact thing, that reality shifting lag time. Stay with us.
在气候问题上，你没这种感觉吗？也许在过去几年这个国家的政治走向，或者有时在个人新闻上。意识到你对已经发生的事情毫无准备，那种冲击感。今天，我们听到一些人们正挣扎于这种现实滞后性的故事。请继续收听。
Act One, It's Probably Nothing. From the very beginning of the war in Ukraine, Elena Kostyuchenko was there, arriving the day after Russia invaded, finding and writing stories that were shocking. In the city of Kherson, she talked to people who told her they'd been tortured by Russian soldiers.
第一幕，这可能没什么。从战争在乌克兰爆发之初，埃琳娜·科斯秋琴科就在那里。她在俄罗斯入侵的第二天到达，发现并撰写了一些令人震惊的故事。在赫尔松市，她采访了一些人，他们告诉她曾遭到俄罗斯士兵的拷打。
She found the place where they'd been held captive. She got the names of dozens of people who had been kidnapped. She's a longtime Russian journalist, publishing in the country's leading independent newspaper, Novaya Gazeta.
她找到了他们被囚禁的地方。她拿到了数十名被绑架者的名单。她是一位资深的俄罗斯记者，为国内领先的独立报纸《新报》撰稿。
And she wrote this essay called "How They Tried to Kill Me" that we thought of for today's show because it shows so clearly how, during a time when everything is changing quickly, like in a war, your perception of what is happening around you can lag way behind the reality, even when other people are telling you straight to your face that things are different now.
她写了一篇题为《他们是如何试图杀死我的》的文章，我们今天选这篇是因为它清楚地表明，在一个一切都在迅速变化的时期（比如战争），你对周围正在发生的事情的认知可能会远远落后于现实，即使别人直截了当地告诉你情况已经变了。
It's read for us by Bela Shayevich, and it starts about a month into the war. Elena spent that first month reporting from Ukrainian cities that were under Russian attack or occupation.
由贝拉·沙耶维奇为我们朗读，故事开始于战争爆发大约一个月后。埃琳娜在第一个月里一直在乌克兰遭到俄罗斯袭击或占领的城市报道。
In those weeks, I could only focus on what was directly in front of me, where I could find electricity, where I could shower, how to cross the front lines for a story, how I could document everything I was seeing. I was surrounded by catastrophe, figuring out how to operate inside of a catastrophe.
在那些周里，我只能专注于眼前的事情：哪里能找到电，哪里能洗澡，如何穿过前线去报道，如何记录我所看到的一切。我被灾难包围，设法在灾难中运作。
What I couldn't see then, and I'm beginning to understand now, was the whole bigger picture of what had been unleashed since the invasion. There were new dangers now and new rules. I couldn't foresee how much my world was going to change.
当时我无法看清，而现在开始理解的是，自入侵以来所释放出的整个更大图景。现在有了新的危险和规则。我无法预见我的世界会发生多大的变化。
First, my newspaper collapsed. I was at a checkpoint when I learned that Novaya Gazeta, the paper that I'd worked for 17 years, was ceasing operations under pressure from the Russian government. In some ways, I'd been expecting it. Other Russian media outlets were shutting down left and right. But still, the pain of it was unbearable. Novaya was like a second family to me.
首先，我的报社倒闭了。我在一个检查站得知，我工作了17年的《新报》在俄罗斯政府的压力下停止运营。在某种程度上，我预料到了。其他俄罗斯媒体一个接一个地关门。但那种痛苦依然无法承受。《新报》就像我的第二个家。
When I got the news, I'd been planning to go to Mariupol. Mariupol was still resisting Russian incursion. I decided that I was going to stick to my plan-- go to Mariupol anyway, publish whatever I wrote wherever I could. I spent the afternoon before I was supposed to go in a hotel. I was trying to gather my strength.
当我得知消息时，我正计划前往马里乌波尔。马里乌波尔当时仍在抵抗俄罗斯的入侵。我决定坚持原计划——还是要去马里乌波尔，无论在哪里都能发表我写的东西。我把出发前的一下午时间待在酒店里。我试图聚集力量。
A colleague from Novaya called me. She asked me if I was still planning on going to Mariupol. I was taken aback. Only two people from the newspaper knew that I was supposed to go there. I said, yeah, I'm going tomorrow. And she said, my sources have gotten in touch with me. They know that you're going to Mariupol. They said that the Kadyrovites have orders to find you. They're not just going to hold you. They're going to kill you. Those are their orders.
一位《新报》的同事打电话给我。她问我是否还打算去马里乌波尔。我很吃惊。报社只有两个人知道我要去那里。我说，是的，我明天去。她说，我的消息来源联系我了。他们知道你要去马里乌波尔。他们说卡德罗夫分队有命令要找到你。他们不仅仅是扣留你，他们要杀了你。这就是他们的命令。
It was like running into a wall. I went deaf. Everything went white. I said, I don't believe you. And she said, that's what I said, too. I told them I don't believe them, but then they played me a recording of you talking to somebody about going to Mariupol, planning your trip. I recognized your voice.
就像撞上了一堵墙。我失聪了。周围的一切都变成了白色。我说，我不相信你。她说，我也这么说。我告诉他们我不相信，但他们放了一段录音，是你和某人谈论去马里乌波尔的计划。我认出了你的声音。
She hung up, and I sat down on the bed I didn't think anything. I just sat there. 40 minutes later, my source from Ukrainian Military Reconnaissance called me. He said, we have information that an assassination of a female journalist from Novaya Gazeta is being organized in Ukraine. An all points bulletin on you has been sent out to every Russian checkpoint.
她挂断了电话，我坐在床上，什么也没想。我只是坐在那儿。40分钟后，我的乌克兰军事侦察消息来源打电话给我。他说，我们得到消息，在乌克兰正在组织一场针对一名《新报》女记者的刺杀行动。你已经被列入所有俄罗斯检查站的通缉名单。
I couldn't stand the idea that they were going to stop me from reporting on their massive atrocities. I decided to give myself another 24 hours to figure out another plan for getting to Mariupol.
我无法接受他们阻止我报道他们大规模暴行的念头。我决定再给自己24小时寻找前往马里乌波尔的其他计划。
The following morning, I woke up to messages from an editor at Novaya. The Russian Prosecutor General's Office and the government censor had sent them letters demanding they take my reporting from Ukraine down from their website. The authorities said that if Novaya didn't take my stories off of the website, the whole site would be taken down. Novaya took my stories off of the site. Somehow, this is what crushed me. I started crying and couldn't stop.
第二天早上，我醒来看到《新报》一位编辑的消息。俄罗斯总检察长办公室和政府审查机构写信要求他们删除我网站上关于乌克兰的报道。当局说如果《新报》不撤掉文章，整个网站就会被封锁。《新报》删除了我的文章。不知为何，这让我崩溃了。我开始哭，无法停止。
Then rage came in place of the tears. I decided I would go to Mariupol, no matter what. I kept trying to find another road in, a road that didn't exist. The only thing that ultimately stopped me from going was thinking about what would happen to whoever agreed to take me in their car. If I got killed, they wouldn't be spared either. The next night, I left Ukraine.
随后，愤怒取代了泪水。我决定无论如何都要去马里乌波尔。我一直在试图寻找另一条路，一条并不存在的路。最终阻止我前往的唯一因素是考虑到如果我同意搭别人的车，他们会遭遇什么。如果我被杀了，他们也难逃一劫。第二天晚上，我离开了乌克兰。
I left in a really bad state. I had lice, mumps, and PTSD. My friends took me in. My girlfriend Yana came from Russia. She tended to me. My plan was to get better, finish the book I was writing, and go back to Russia. All of my work, my mother and sister, my entire life, all of that was there. I couldn't yet see that in this new world, I wouldn't be able to go home.
我离开时状态非常糟糕。我得了虱子、腮腺炎和创伤后应激障碍。朋友们收留了我。我的女朋友亚娜从俄罗斯赶来照顾我。我的计划是养好身体，完成我正在写的书，然后回到俄罗斯。我所有的工作、我的母亲和妹妹，我的一生都在那里。我还没意识到，在这个新世界里，我再也回不去家了。
At the end of April, two months into the war, Novaya's editor-in-chief Dmitry Muratov called me. He spoke in a very gentle voice. He said, I know that you want to come home, but you cannot go back to Russia. They're going to kill you. I hung up the phone and started screaming. I stood in the street and screamed. At the end of September, I got in touch with Muratov again. I asked him to find out whether I could return to Russia now. He called me back several days later. No, no, no.
四月底，战争爆发两个月后，《新报》主编德米特里·穆拉托夫打来电话。他用非常温柔的声音说，我知道你想回家，但你不能回俄罗斯。他们会杀了你。我挂了电话开始尖叫。我站在街上大喊。九月底，我再次联系穆拉托夫。我让他查查我现在是否能回俄罗斯。几天后他回电说：不，不，不。
I found an apartment in Berlin and stayed there. I began working for the largest remaining independent Russian media outlet, Meduza. We decided that my first reporting trip was going to be to Iran. And then we decided that after Iran, I would go back to Ukraine. I decided to go to Munich to apply for a visa at the Ukrainian consulate there in person. Their website had been attacked by hackers and wasn't letting me file for a visa online.
我在柏林找了套公寓住下。我开始为俄罗斯最大的独立媒体《梅杜扎》工作。我们决定我的第一次报道行程是去伊朗。然后我们决定，从伊朗回来后，我就回乌克兰。我决定去慕尼黑亲自申请签证。他们的网站被黑客攻击了，无法在线申请。
There is no justification for what I did next, and there cannot be, but I need to confess that when I was planning my trip to Munich, I corresponded about it over Facebook Messenger. It wasn't secure at that time, and I knew that, but I thought, I'm not in Russia. I'm in Germany. I believed that Europe was safe. The basic tenets of my security, the protocols I'd been following for years, didn't even occur to me. I left myself exposed to what happened next at all of these moments that I can see so clearly when I look back.
对于我接下来的行为没有任何辩解的理由，也不可能有，但我得承认，当我计划去慕尼黑时，我在Facebook Messenger上进行了沟通。那时它并不安全，我是知道的，但我认为，我不在俄罗斯，我在德国。我相信欧洲是安全的。我多年来遵循的基本安全准则甚至都没在我脑海里闪过。我让自己暴露在接下来发生的事情中，当我回首往事时，这些时刻清晰可见。
On the evening of October 17, I took an overnight train to Munich. I took off my shoes, lay down on my seat, and slept. People walked past me. They'd bump into my feet. I kept sleeping. On the morning of October 18, I arrived. I went to meet my friend, tried to sleep, then went to the consulate. But I still wasn't able to apply for a visa. Now, their internal system was glitching. We decided that I would come back another day.
10月17日晚上，我坐夜车去慕尼黑。我脱掉鞋子躺在座位上睡觉。人们从我身边走过，碰到我的脚。我一直在睡。10月18日早晨我抵达了。我去找朋友，试图小睡，然后去了领事馆。但我还是没能申请到签证。现在是他们的内部系统故障了。我们决定改天再去。
My friend picked me up at the consulate, and we went out to lunch. We sat outside at a restaurant. While we were eating, two different groups of her acquaintances happened to run into us. They came up to our table. There was a man and then two women. I thought, what a small town Munich is. It's like everyone here knows each other. I went to the bathroom and then came back. All I could think about was the visa. It was unlikely that I was going to get it, but what if it worked out?
朋友在领事馆接我，我们去吃了午饭。我们坐在餐馆外面。吃饭时，她的两组熟人恰好遇到了我们。他们走到我们的桌子旁。先是一个男人，然后是两个女人。我想，慕尼黑真是个小城市。好像这里每个人都认识。我去了趟洗手间然后回来。我脑子里只想着签证。申请成功的可能性不大，但万一呢？
After lunch, my friend took me back to the train station. As we approached it, she said, listen, I have to tell you something. You smell bad. Let me find you some deodorant. But she couldn't find any. I remember I was really surprised. She's a very tactful person. She would have never said anything to me if I hadn't actually smelled terrible.
午餐后，朋友送我回火车站。当我们走近车站时，她说，听着，我得告诉你一件事。你身上有股味儿。让我帮你找点除臭剂。但她没找到。我记得我当时非常惊讶。她是一个非常讲究分寸的人。如果我身上真的没难闻，她绝对不会对我说这种话。
When I got on the train, I found my seat and immediately went to the bathroom. I wet some paper towels and started wiping myself off with them. I was covered in sweat. The sweat smelled strong and strange, like rotten fruit. I sat down and started reading the manuscript of my book.
上火车后，我找到座位立即去了洗手间。我弄湿了一些纸巾开始擦拭身体。我浑身是汗。汗水味道很浓且奇怪，像腐烂的水果。我坐下来开始读我的书稿。
After a while, I realized that I was just reading the same paragraph over and over. My head ached. I had gotten over COVID a few weeks earlier. I thought, do I really have it again? I was covered in sweat. I went back to the bathroom and wiped myself off again.
过了一会儿，我意识到自己一直在反复读同一段话。我头痛欲裂。我几周前刚得过新冠。我想，我难道又感染了吗？我满身是汗。我回到洗手间又擦了一次。
When I got out at the Berlin train station, it hit me that I couldn't figure out how to get home. I've tried to describe what was going on in my mind at the train station, and the closest I can get is this. A friend told me once about what it was like having a stroke. She knew she was having a stroke. She understood that she needed to get down the stairs of her house and go out into the street, but she couldn't understand stairs.
当我在柏林火车站下车时，我突然意识到自己不知道怎么回家了。我试图描述我在车站时的心理状态，最贴切的就是这个：一位朋友曾告诉我她中风时的感受。她知道自己中风了。她明白她需要下楼走出家门，但她无法理解楼梯。
I asked her, you mean you couldn't walk down the stairs? She said, no. It wasn't about being able to walk. I couldn't understand the concept of stairs at all. For me, the idea of space itself felt weird. In Berlin, it's easy to transfer from the train to the subway. I'd done it many times. But suddenly, I didn't understand getting from one platform to another, the whole idea of changing levels. My mind failed. I was terrified.
我问她，你是说你不能走下楼梯吗？她说，不，不是能不能走的问题。我根本无法理解楼梯这个概念。对我来说，空间本身的想法都很奇怪。在柏林，从火车换乘地铁很容易。我做过很多次。但突然间，我不明白怎么从一个站台到另一个站台，换层这个概念我完全理解不了。我的大脑崩溃了。我很害怕。
Finally, I did manage to get on the subway platform, but when I realized that the trains went in both directions and I would have to figure out which way to go, I burst into tears. People on the platform helped me get on the right train and told me to go two stops and then get off. I did. On the stairs, I got short of breath. I thought to myself, this fucking COVID has really messed me up this time.
最终，我确实设法到了地铁站台，但当我意识到列车是双向的，我必须弄清楚该走哪边时，我大哭起来。站台上的人帮我上了正确的列车，告诉我坐两站然后下车。我照做了。在楼梯上，我感到呼吸困难。我心想，这该死的新冠这次真的把我害惨了。
I didn't once think, maybe I've been poisoned. I didn't know that what was possible had shifted. In the old world, before the war, Russian reporters had been poisoned, but only inside of Russia. Russians who were poisoned outside the country had mostly been former security services people, not reporters, like me.
我一次都没想过，也许我中毒了。我不知道可能发生的现实已经改变。在旧世界，战争爆发前，俄罗斯记者确实被下过毒，但那是在俄罗斯国内。在国外中毒的俄罗斯人大多是前特务人员，而不是像我这样的记者。
As soon as I got home, I went to sleep. I hoped that I would feel better when I got up, but I only got worse. A pain in my stomach woke me up. The feeling was strange, very strong, but like it kept getting switched on and off. I felt so dizzy. The room was spinning. I barely slept. My head kept spinning whenever I sat down or got up. On the third day, it became clear that I was not going anywhere and that whatever I had wasn't COVID.
回到家后，我立刻睡了。我希望醒来能好点，但情况却恶化了。胃部的疼痛把我疼醒了。那种感觉很奇怪，非常强烈，但好像一直在开关。我感到非常头晕。房间在旋转。我几乎没睡。每当我坐下或站起来时，头就在不停旋转。第三天，很明显我哪也去不了，而且我得的肯定不是新冠。
It isn't easy to see a doctor in Berlin. And I didn't know how to navigate the medical system. I wasn't able to get an appointment until 10 days after I got ill. The appointment was at a regular clinic in my neighborhood. The doctors, there were two of them, both immediately said that I had long COVID, but they did an ultrasound, too, just in case-- all clear. I also got them to do some blood tests. I came out of the clinic consoled. It was nothing. I'd get better soon.
在柏林看医生不容易。我不知道如何驾驭这个医疗系统。直到我生病10天后，我才挂上号。医生是在我社区的一家普通诊所。两位医生都立刻说我得了长新冠，但为了保险起见，他们还是给我做了超声波检查——结果完全正常。我还让他们给我做了验血。我走出诊所时感到宽慰。没什么大事。我很快就会好起来的。
Then the blood tests came back. They were bad. The levels of ALT and AST, two enzymes in my liver, were five times above normal. They tested my urine. There was blood in it. The doctors began taking me seriously. I was referred to another more experienced specialist. She said that it was most likely viral hepatitis, which I had contracted during the war. We'll figure out which hepatitis it is, and then we'll treat it, she said. The hepatitis tests came back negative.
接着验血报告出来了。结果很糟糕。ALT和AST这两种肝酶的水平高出正常值五倍。他们检查了我的尿液。里面有血。医生开始重视起来。我被转诊给另一位更有经验的专家。她说很可能是我在战争期间感染了病毒性肝炎。她说，我们会弄清楚是哪种肝炎，然后进行治疗。但肝炎检测结果呈阴性。
My symptoms kept changing. My face started swelling. My fingers started looking like sausages. Then it was my feet. I lost sight of my chin. My face was no longer my face. I couldn't recognize myself in the mirror. Sometimes the palms of my hands and the bottoms of my feet would start to burn, turning red and shiny.
我的症状在不断变化。我的脸开始肿胀。手指看起来像香肠。然后是脚。我的下巴看不见了。我的脸不再是我的脸。我在镜子里认不出自己了。有时手掌和脚底开始燃烧，变得通红发亮。
A few weeks into these symptoms, a friend of mine came to Berlin. He was horrified at the state I was in. He said, do you understand that you may have been poisoned? Have you talked to your doctors about that? I said, I haven't, and I'm not going to. That's stupid. I said, don't try to infect me with your paranoia.
这些症状持续了几周后，一位朋友来到柏林。他被我当时的状态吓坏了。他说，你明白你可能中毒了吗？你跟你的医生讨论过这个问题吗？我说，我还没谈，而且我也不打算谈。那太蠢了。我说，别想用你的偏执来传染我。
Everything was exhausting, but I stopped being able to sleep altogether. It was as though my brain had forgotten how to fall asleep. My hepatic enzyme levels kept rising. I kept going to doctors. The doctors would come up with theories, test them, come up with new ones-- autoimmune diseases, systemic diseases, acute complicated complex pyelonephritis.
一切都让人精疲力竭，但我已经彻底睡不着了。好像我的大脑忘记了如何入睡。我的肝酶水平持续升高。我一直在看医生。医生们提出理论，测试它们，然后又提出新的——自身免疫性疾病、系统性疾病、急性复杂性肾盂肾炎。
Finally, a doctor asked me, is it possible that you've been poisoned? I replied, no, I'm not that dangerous. I told Yana about it later, and we laughed. She said, of course. It's the simplest explanation. A Russian journalist? She must have been poisoned.
最终，一位医生问我，你有没有可能中毒了？我回答说，不，我没那么危险。我后来告诉了亚娜，我们笑了。她说，当然了。这是最简单的解释。一个俄罗斯记者？她肯定是中毒了。
In December, two months after my trip to Munich, I went back to my neighborhood doctor. I got a new round of tests, and the results had gotten worse. My ALT was seven times above normal. We sat in the doctor's office. Then she said, Elena, there are two theories left. The first one is that the antidepressants you're on may have suddenly started working aberrantly. But you recently changed medications, and your symptoms and test results haven't changed.
12月，我慕尼黑之行两个月后，我回到社区医生那里。我做了新一轮检查，结果更糟了。我的ALT高出正常值七倍。我们坐在医生办公室里。她说，埃琳娜，只剩下两个理论了。第一个是，你服用的抗抑郁药可能突然发生了异常反应。但你最近换了药，你的症状和检测结果并没有改变。
That's why we have a second theory. Please try to stay calm. You may have been poisoned. I laughed. The doctor stayed silent. I said, that's impossible. She said, we've ruled out all other options. I'm sorry. You need to go to the Toxicology Department at Charité Hospital.
这就是为什么我们有第二个理论。请尽量保持冷静。你可能中毒了。我笑了。医生保持沉默。我说，那是不可能的。她说，我们排除了所有其他选择。我很抱歉。你需要去夏里特医院的毒理科。
I spent the next three days in the apartment, just lying there and thinking. At first, I told Yana that it was all stupid and that the doctors had made a mistake. They just couldn't figure out how to diagnose me and didn't want to run any more tests. Then I got in touch with Meduza, my employer. And we started trying to plan our next steps.
接下来的三天我待在公寓里，躺在那儿思考。起初，我告诉亚娜这全是胡说八道，医生肯定弄错了。他们只是想不出怎么诊断我，不想再做更多测试。然后我联系了我的雇主《梅杜扎》。我们开始着手规划后续步骤。
In order to get blood tests done for poisoning in Berlin, you have to go to the police. So I did. They sent me straight to the hospital from the precinct. The police officers came, too, to talk to me and the doctors.
要在柏林进行中毒验血，你必须去警察局。所以我去了。他们直接从派出所把我送到了医院。警察也赶来跟我和医生谈话。
My first round of questioning with the Berlin criminal police lasted nine hours. They wanted to know everything, what I was working on, what I was planning to work on, who I had been in contact with in Ukraine, who I was talking to now. I had to reconstruct October 17 and 18, my trip to Munich, minute by minute.
我第一次接受柏林刑事警察的盘问持续了九个小时。他们想知道一切，我在做什么，计划做什么，在乌克兰和谁联系过，现在和谁在通话。我不得不一分钟一分钟地还原10月17日和18日，也就是我慕尼黑之行。
The police checked my clothes and apartment for radiation, my body, too. They took the clothes I traveled to Munich with. Then the police did a safety check of my apartment. An officer asked me, why are your blinds open? You could easily be shot from the balcony across the way. They told me I needed to follow new safety protocols. Like what? I asked. Move. Take different routes home. Don't get cabs directly to your destination. Get out of cars a few blocks away. Wear sunglasses.
警察检查了我的衣服和公寓有没有辐射，也检查了我的身体。他们带走了我去慕尼黑时穿的衣服。然后警方对我的公寓进行了安全检查。一名警官问我，为什么你的百叶窗开着？对面阳台的人很容易就能朝你开枪。他们告诉我需要遵守新的安全规程。比如什么？我问。搬家。走不同的回家路线。不要直接坐出租车到目的地。在几个街区外下车。戴上太阳镜。
The police officers were mad at me. They didn't show it at first. But after the third round of questioning, we started talking. The lead detective said, we can't understand why it took you this long to come to us. You should have called the police right away, as soon as you felt sick on the train. We would have met you at the station.
警官对我感到很恼火。起初他们没表现出来。但在第三轮盘问后，我们开始聊天。首席侦探说，我们不明白为什么你拖了这么久才来找我们。你应该在火车上感到不适时就立刻报警。我们本可以在车站接你的。
But I didn't think I'd been poisoned. I'm still not sure. Why didn't you think so? It seemed crazy to me. And I'm in Europe. I felt like I was safe here. That is what drives us up the wall, the detective said. You people come here and act like you're on vacation, like this is some kind of paradise. It doesn't even occur to you to keep yourself safe. The Russian Special Services are active in Germany. We have political killings here.
但我没想到我中毒了。我现在仍然不确定。你为什么没那样想？对我来说这太疯狂了。而且我在欧洲。我觉得我在这里很安全。这就是让我们抓狂的地方，侦探说。你们这些人来到这里表现得像在度假，像这里是什么天堂一样。甚至根本没想过要保护自己。俄罗斯特务机构在德国很活跃。我们这里发生过政治谋杀。
The senior detective had already run two previous investigations of Russian citizens being attacked in Berlin. One was shot and killed in Berlin in 2019. The killer, Vadim Krasikov, received a life sentence in Germany for murder, quote, on the orders of the Russian government.
高级侦探此前已经调查过两起俄罗斯公民在柏林遇袭的案件。其中一人于2019年在柏林被枪杀。凶手瓦迪姆·克拉西科夫在德国被判处终身监禁，罪名是“奉俄罗斯政府之命”谋杀。
A year earlier, the same detective investigated the apparent poisoning of a prominent critic of President Putin, Pyotr Verzilov. But, the detective said, we weren't able to establish anything in that case, not even the substance used. I asked, how come? Because it's impossible to ask a lab, was this person poisoned? You could only ask if there was a specific substance present in their body. And there are thousands of poisonous substances. That's why it's such a popular means of assassination.
一年前，同一位侦探调查了普京总统的杰出批评者彼得·维尔齐洛夫疑似中毒的案件。但是，侦探说，我们在那个案件中无法确定任何事情，甚至连使用的物质都查不出。我问，为什么？因为询问实验室“这个人是否中毒”是不可能的。你只能询问身体中是否存在某种特定物质。而有成千上万种有毒物质。这就是为什么它是如此受欢迎的暗杀手段。
The Berlin police do not have any answers for me. Four months after I'd first gone to them, the prosecutor general's office informed me that they had not found, quote, "any indication that there had been an attempt to kill me." Quote, "Blood test results do not conclusively indicate poisoning."
柏林警方对我没有任何答案。在我第一次找他们四个月后，检察长办公室通知我，他们没有发现“任何试图杀害我的迹象”。声称：“血液检测结果并不能明确表明中毒。”
But in the meantime, I was approached by the editor-in-chief of online Russian investigative news site Insider at a journalism conference. He took me aside. Elena, I have a personal question. But first, I need to tell you something. Christo Grozev from Bellingcat and I have been investigating a series of poisonings in Europe. All the known targets are female Russian journalists. I want to ask you. You haven't written anything for a long time. Is it because you've been sick?
但与此同时，我在一次新闻会议上遇到了俄罗斯调查新闻网站《内部人》的总编辑。他把我拉到一边。埃琳娜，我有个私人问题。但首先，我得告诉你一件事。调查新闻网站“贝林猫”的克里斯托·格罗泽夫和我一直在调查欧洲的一系列中毒事件。所有已知的目标都是俄罗斯女记者。我想问问你。你很久没写任何东西了。是因为你一直在生病吗？
And I told him what I'm telling you now. The doctors and toxicologists Bellingcat consulted came to the conclusion that the most likely explanation of what happened to me was that I'd been poisoned with an organochlorine compound. I've passed this information on to the Berlin police.
我告诉了他我现在正在告诉你的事情。贝林猫咨询的医生和毒理学家得出的结论是，发生在我身上最可能的解释是我被一种有机氯化合物毒害了。我已经把这些信息传达给了柏林警察。
I've thought a lot about why it took me so long to believe I'd been poisoned. During my time at Novaya Gazeta, four of my colleagues were killed. I organized the funeral of Khimki journalist Mikhail Beketov. He'd been a friend.
我对自己为什么花这么长时间才相信自己被下毒深思熟虑。在《新报》工作期间，我的四名同事被杀。我组织了希姆基记者米哈伊尔·别克托夫的葬礼。他曾是我的朋友。
I knew that journalists got murdered, but I didn't want to believe that they could kill me. I was protected from this thought by revulsion, shame, and exhaustion. It disgusted me to think that there were people who wanted me dead. I was ashamed to talk about it, even with loved ones, let alone the police. And I felt how exhausted I was, how little strength I had left, that I wouldn't be able to go on the run again.
我知道记者会被谋杀，但我不想相信他们会杀我。厌恶、羞耻和疲惫保护我不去想这一点。想到有人想让我死，这让我感到恶心。我感到羞耻，不敢谈论这件事，即使是对亲人，更不用说警察了。我感到自己是多么疲惫，剩下的力量是多么微薄，我无法再继续逃亡了。
At this point, the pain, nausea, and swelling have gone. But I still have very little energy. There are days when I can't do anything. I feel useless. Reporting is what has given me purpose my whole life. My partner, Yana, and I have to move every month now. The Berlin police say we need to, as much as we can, for our safety.
此时，疼痛、恶心和肿胀已经消失。但我依然没什么精力。有些日子我什么也做不了。我感到无用。报道是我一生中给予我目标的东西。我的伴侣亚娜和我现在不得不每个月搬一次家。柏林警察说，为了我们的安全，我们需要尽可能多地搬家。
We have to decide for ourselves how much moving that means. It's so exhausting every time-- new languages, new currencies, new neighborhoods, packing, unpacking, over and over again. It's hard for anyone to get a sense of what's safe or what's dangerous in our current reality. Like, what if moving around so much is actually stupid, and we're driving ourselves crazy for nothing? Does anyone really know what Yana and I are supposed to do?
我们不得不自己决定这意味着搬多少次。每次都精疲力竭——新的语言、新的货币、新的街区，一遍又一遍地打包、拆包。在这个现实中，很难有人能感受到什么是安全，什么是危险。比如，如果搬来搬去其实很蠢，我们只是白白把自己折磨疯了呢？真的有人知道亚娜和我该怎么做吗？
But the reality that we found ourselves in isn't actually totally new to me. There's something familiar in it. Even though Russia is my home, I never felt safe there. So for me, the feeling of home is the feeling of being unsafe. Now, I walk around foreign cities the same way I used to walk around Russian cities, paying close attention to the people and things around me, listening, watching, always weighing my risks. The habit of being vigilant actually feels comforting. It is both normal and not. You can take the girl out of Russia, but Russia may not let you go.
但我们发现自己身处的现实对我来说并不完全陌生。其中有些熟悉感。即使俄罗斯是我的家，我在那里也从未感到安全。所以对我来说，家的感觉就是不安全的感觉。现在，我在国外城市走动的方式和我过去在俄罗斯城市走动的方式一样，密切关注周围的人和事物，倾听、观察，总是权衡我的风险。这种保持警惕的习惯实际上让人感到安慰。它既正常又不正常。你可以把女孩带离俄罗斯，但俄罗斯可能不会让你走。
Bela Shayevich reading an essay by Elena Kostyuchenko. This essay first appeared in n+1, translated into English by Bela. The book Elena talks about in the essay has come out. It's full of intimate, eye-opening stories of people all over Russia. It's called I Love Russia, Reporting from a Lost Country. The radio adaptation of her essay was produced by Nancy Updike and Valerie Kipnis.
贝拉·沙耶维奇朗读埃琳娜·科斯秋琴科的文章。这篇文章最早出现在《n+1》杂志上，由贝拉译成英文。埃琳娜文中提到的书已经出版了。书里充满了俄罗斯各地人们亲密而令人大开眼界的真实故事。书名是《我爱俄罗斯：来自一个失落国家的报道》。她文章的广播改编版由南希·厄普代克和瓦莱丽·基普尼斯制作。
Coming up, something good happens suddenly to comedian Tig Notaro, but she has trouble catching up to the reality of that. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
稍后，喜剧演员蒂格·诺塔罗突然遇到了一件好事，但她很难适应那个现实。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our show today is about moments when we all find ourselves catching up to some new reality that we're living inside, moments when we're shocked to realize that we are unprepared for what has already happened.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目是关于当我们身处其中时，发现自己正在赶上某种新现实的时刻，当我们意识到对已经发生的事情毫无准备而感到震惊的时刻。
I don't know about you, but I feel like we get a lot of those moments these last few years. They happen when they're big, world shaking changes-- wars and politics, pandemics, the climate. But they also happen with small, personal upheavals. We find ourselves catching up to some new reality that we find ourselves in.
我不知道你怎么样，但我感觉过去几年我们经历了很多这样的时刻。当世界发生重大动荡——战争、政治、大流行、气候变化时，它们就会发生。但它们也会发生在微小的个人动荡中。我们发现自己正在赶上我们身处的新现实。
We have an example of that happening that got recorded on tape, like as it happened, somebody who was not adjusted to the new reality, their heads still sort of spinning, trying to get a grip on where they now found themselves. This is going to be the second act of our show. Act Two, We At The Hotel, Motel, Very Locked In. And the person this happens to is one of our regular contributors, Tig Notaro. She was on tour, doing stand up in Sacramento, California, in a big theater, the Crest Theater.
我们有一个恰好被录音记录下来的例子，就像它发生的时候一样，有人没有调整到新现实，他们的头脑仍然有些眩晕，试图掌握他们现在发现自己身处的位置。这将是我们节目的第二幕。第二幕，我们在酒店，汽车旅馆，被锁死。经历这一切的人是我们的一位常驻贡献者，蒂格·诺塔罗。她当时正在巡演，在加利福尼亚州萨克拉门托的一家大剧院——克雷斯特剧院做脱口秀。
Put your hands together for Tig Notaro!
大家一起鼓掌欢迎蒂格·诺塔罗！
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
And right before she got on stage, this thing happened to her. And you can hear it in her voice. In this recording, she is still not over this. Mentally, she has barely caught up to the fact that she is on stage in front of all these people, and she talks it out, brings them along for her mental ride with this.
就在她登台前，这件事发生了。你可以从她的声音中听出来。在这段录音中，她仍然没走出来。从心理上讲，她几乎没赶上她已经站在观众面前的事实，她把这件事说了出来，带着观众一起经历她的心理过程。
Oh, my gosh. Sacramento, you have no idea how happy I am to see you. You really don't. You don't know how happy I am to see you. I had no idea how happy I was going to be to see you. I was already happy, but what you don't know-- and this is going to sound funny, but it wasn't-- in your fair city, at my hotel, I was locked in my bathroom for 30 minutes. You're laughing. It was not funny.
天哪。萨克拉门托，你们不知道我看到你们有多高兴。你们真的不知道。你们不知道看到你们我有多开心。我根本不知道看到你们我会这么开心。我本来就很开心，但你们不知道的是——这听起来很好笑，但其实一点也不——在你们美丽的城市，在我的酒店里，我被锁在洗手间里30分钟。你们在笑。这真的一点都不好笑。
And I was like, oh, I can't believe I'm out of there. I don't know if you can see. I was trying to break out of my bathroom. I have bruising and swelling. That's what was going on when you were out to dinner before the show. I was trapped in my bathroom at my hotel.
我当时就在想，哦，我不相信我能出来。不知道你们能不能看出来。我当时正试图冲出洗手间。我有淤青和肿胀。这就是当你们演出前吃晚餐时正在发生的事情。我被困在酒店的洗手间里。
Sorry.
抱歉。
What? Yes. I appreciate it. And you know what? I was on my way over here, going, oh, I cannot wait to see these people. I will never forget you. I truly was having a panic-- picture 30 minutes. You know those locks that do this? And they go into the wall and they lock down? Wouldn't open. Stuck 30 minutes.
什么？是的。我很感激。你们知道吗？我在来这儿的路上一直想着，天哪，我迫不及待想见到这些人。我永远不会忘记你们。我真的在那时经历了恐慌——想象一下30分钟。你们知道那种这样的锁吗？它们锁进墙里然后锁死？打不开。困了30分钟。
Tig, move on. I know. But it wasn't even 30 minutes ago that that was happening. In fact, I know there's a woman here, right? Clap. I saw you in the hall at the hotel. Are you here? Yeah. I had just gotten out of my bathroom. She's like, oh, I'm going to your show. I was like, oh, god, you have no idea.
蒂格，继续吧。我知道。但那件事发生还没到30分钟。其实，我知道这里有一位女士，对吧？鼓掌。我在酒店大堂看到你了。你在这儿吗？是的。我刚从洗手间出来。她说，哦，我要去看你的演出。我说，哦，天哪，你不知道我刚经历了什么。
You know what I learned? I can't break a wall down. I can't kick a door down. I was like, OK. You're not going to die. You're not going to die. What could kill you? Nothing, except yourself. Because I was truly like, do I just knock myself out? That's a thought. I was like, do I slam my head in the wall and just go unconscious? Because I can't deal with this. And then I was like, or do I just get in the shower and then just take another shower and pretend like this isn't happening? And I was like, no!
你们知道我学到了什么吗？我无法拆毁墙壁。我无法踹开门。我当时想，好吧。你不会死的。你不会死的。什么能杀了你？没什么，除了你自己。因为我当时真的在想，我是不是该把自己打晕？这是个想法。我当时想，我是不是该把头撞在墙上直接失去知觉？因为我应付不了这个。然后我想，或者我该进淋浴间，再冲个澡，假装没发生过？然后我对自己说，不！
I said, how did you get out?
我说，你是怎么出来的？
Same question for you. I don't know. How did I get out? I called Stephanie. I was backstage just now, calling her, and I was like, I just have to talk to you. I have to tell you what I just went through. I was just traumatized. I have to go on stage. And she said, how did it open? And I said, honestly? I don't know. I don't know how it opened.
我也想问你这个问题。我不知道。我是怎么出来的？我给斯蒂芬妮打了电话。我刚才在后台，给她打电话，我说，我必须跟你说话。我得告诉你我刚经历了什么。我刚才遭受了精神创伤。我得登台了。她说，门是怎么开的？我说，老实说？我不知道。我不知道它怎么开的。
I am not a religious person. And I don't really believe in magic. But one or the other happened in that room in my hotel tonight. Magic or the Good Lord opened the bathroom. I forgot to tell you what room I'm in. My voice is still shaking. That's how recent it was.
我不是一个有宗教信仰的人。我也不太相信魔法。但今晚在我酒店的那个房间里发生了一件事，要么是魔法，要么是上帝打开了洗手间。我忘了告诉你们我住在哪个房间了。我的声音还在颤抖。事情发生得太近了。
Aw, you guys are kind. And you know what? I knew it in my bones. I was like, I know they're going to be good to me. And I thought, don't talk about this. I can't help myself. I was still saying it to myself as I walked up the stairs. It's like, don't. Don't talk about it. Just go into your material. And I was like, I was locked in my bathroom for 30 minutes.
啊，你们太善良了。你们知道吗？我骨子里感觉得到。我想，我知道他们会对我很好的。我想，别谈这件事了。我控制不住自己。当我走上台阶时，我还在对自己说。这就像，别说。别谈它了。直接进入你的素材吧。但我还是说了，我被锁在洗手间30分钟。
And I don't mean to really bum you out, but I was crying. I know! I was crying, and I was like, I know this is going to be funny. But I didn't think it was going to be tonight. I didn't think the humor was going to come tonight. I thought it was going to be like in a month. And then I was walking up these steps right here, and I was like, just get into your material. I know your head's still stuck in that bathroom, and you're still shaking.
我不是真的想让你们扫兴，但我当时在哭。我知道！我在哭，我想，我知道这会很好笑。但我没想到会是今晚。我不认为幽默会发生在今晚。我想这得过一个月。然后当我走上这些台阶时，我在想，直接进入你的素材。我知道你的脑子还困在那个洗手间里，而且你还在发抖。
I learned like 15 years ago that I'm claustrophobic. I was in a-- what are they called? Elevator? Elevator in DC. And I was with somebody I was newly dating, and then the elevator stopped. And I would hear about people that were claustrophobic, and I didn't understand it. I was like, what is the problem? It's not like anything's happening. And our elevator stopped. Again, newly dating, and I was like, panic! And we were stuck for less than three minutes. Now, picture tonight, 30 minutes.
我15年前才知道我有幽闭恐惧症。我在一个——那个叫什么？电梯？华盛顿的电梯里。我当时和一个刚开始约会的人在一起，然后电梯停了。我会听说有幽闭恐惧症的人，但我理解不了。我当时想，有什么问题？又没发生什么事。然后我们的电梯停了。再一次，刚开始约会，我当时想，恐慌！我们被困了不到三分钟。现在，想象一下今晚，30分钟。
Anyway, we're here. We're here. We're here. And I do appreciate you being here. It's a lot that you went up against to come here-- I mean, not more than me, but--
总之，我们在这儿了。我们在这儿了。我们在这儿了。我确实很感谢你们能来。你们克服了重重困难才来到这儿——我是说，没有我经历的多，但——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Tig Notaro. Her new stand-up special Hello Again comes out in two weeks on Amazon. Her podcast Handsome is available wherever you get your podcasts.
蒂格·诺塔罗。她的新脱口秀特辑《Hello Again》两周后在亚马逊上线。她的播客《Handsome》在任何你获取播客的地方都可以听到。
Act Three, That's My Story and I'm Absolutely Not Sticking to It. So our show today is about moments when we're all catching up to some new reality that we are living inside, and we turn in this act to political realities. One thing that is very particular to being a politician is that it is a politician's actual job to make a new reality.
第三幕，这是我的故事，我绝不坚持到底。我们今天的节目是关于当我们身处其中时发现自己正在赶上新现实的时刻，在这一幕中，我们转向政治现实。作为一名政治家，有一件事非常特别，那就是创造新现实是政治家的实际工作。
So maybe that reality is a world without abortion rights. Maybe it's a world where rich people get taxed a lot more. You see what I'm saying. Maybe you remember that old famous quote from a senior Bush administration official who told a reporter, when we act, we create our own reality.
所以也许那个现实是一个没有堕胎权的世界。也许是一个富人被征收更高税收的世界。你们明白我的意思。也许你们还记得布什政府的一位高级官员对记者说过的那句名言：当我们行动时，我们就创造了自己的现实。
Being a politician means that you think that you're the one who can reshape the reality that the rest of us live in. And with that in mind, we have this very interesting, very local example where you see a politician trying to bend reality to suit his purposes. Zoe Chace explains.
成为一名政治家意味着你认为自己是可以重塑我们其他人所处现实的那个人。考虑到这一点，我们有一个非常有趣、非常本地化的例子，你可以看到一位政治家试图扭曲现实以满足自己的目的。佐伊·切斯来解释一下。
This is a story of a politician who denied the truth, and then admitted it, and then, very publicly, went back to the original denial, as if no one would notice. It starts in November of 2018, down in Monroe, North Carolina.
这是一个关于一位政治家否认真相，然后承认真相，然后非常公开地回到最初否认的故事，就好像没人会注意到一样。这始于2018年11月，在北卡罗来纳州的门罗。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
You know that feeling when you think you have something in the bag, and you're on top of the world about it?
你有没有过这种感觉，当你认为自己胜券在握，并且对此感到世界之巅的时候？
I absolutely want to start tonight by thanking our dear Lord, who has blessed my family and has blessed this campaign and has guided--
今晚我绝对要首先感谢我们亲爱的主，他保佑了我的家庭，保佑了这场竞选，并指导——
That's the position this guy, Mark Harris, was in a few years ago. This was his victory speech. He'd just run for Congress.
这就是这个叫马克·哈里斯的人几年前所处的位置。这是他的胜选演讲。他刚刚竞选国会议员。
I have the greatest family in the world, who has been our rock and has been such a foundation for all of us.
我有世界上最伟大的家庭，他们是我们的磐石，是我们所有人的基础。
This was a very tight race, though, margin of just about 900 votes. And Harris was headed to Washington when word came in he might not have won.
不过这是一场非常激烈的竞争，票数差距只有大约900票。哈里斯正准备前往华盛顿，这时传出消息说他可能没赢。
Election officials in North Carolina unanimously voted not to certify the winner of the state's 9th District congressional election. As it currently stands, Republican Mark Harris holds a 905-vote lead over Democrat Dan McCready, but the Harris campaign is being accused of coordinating an effort to collect ballots from voters and either fill them in for Harris or throw them away if the vote was for McCready. Well, those actions are illegal. And joining me now, outside--
北卡罗来纳州的选举官员一致投票决定不认证该州第九选区国会选举的获胜者。目前，共和党人马克·哈里斯领先民主党人丹·麦克雷迪905票，但哈里斯竞选团队被指控协调努力从选民手中收集选票，如果是投给哈里斯就填上，如果是投给麦克雷迪就扔掉。嗯，这些行为是非法的。现在加入我的是，在外面——
It wasn't long before Mark Harris, former Baptist preacher, was accused of major election fraud. The whole scheme was revealed at a hearing in Raleigh. The testimony was wild, mostly about a political operative Harris had hired, McCrae Dowless.
没过多久，前浸信会牧师马克·哈里斯就被指控犯有重大选举舞弊罪。整个阴谋在罗利的听证会上被揭露。证词非常疯狂，主要是关于哈里斯雇佣的一名政治操盘手，麦克雷·道莱斯。
This guy, McCrae Dowless, there's so much I could say about him, because I did a whole podcast about this. But briefly, he was described as a good old boy who ate, drank, and smoked politics. You could usually find him with a cigarette outside the hardware store in his windbreaker.
这个叫麦克雷·道莱斯的家伙，关于他我有太多的话要说，因为我为此做了一整期播客。但简单来说，他被描述为一个吃、喝、抽政治的“老好人”。你通常能发现他在五金店外穿着防风夹克抽烟。
McCrae had been hired to run Mark Harris's absentee ballot campaign. And down in Bladen County, McCrae allegedly hired people he knew to go around picking up ballots-- illegal-- filling them out-- illegal-- signing for witnesses who weren't there-- illegal. Apparently, he paid a woman named Kelly, who he befriended at the Hardee's drive-thru. He hired his in-law, Jessica. His stepdaughter, Lisa, she testified at the hearing.
麦克雷被雇来管理马克·哈里斯的缺席选票竞选活动。在布雷登县，据称麦克雷雇佣了他认识的人到处去收集选票——非法——填上它们——非法——为不在场的证人签名——非法。显然，他付钱给一个叫凯利的女人，那是他在哈迪斯免下车餐厅结识的。他雇佣了姻亲杰西卡。他的继女丽莎，她在听证会上作了证。
So you were filling in the ovals and voting for other people, right?
所以你当时在涂黑椭圆圈并为别人投票，对吧？
Yes, sir.
是的，长官。
You were voting other people's ballots.
你在投别人的票。
Yes, sir.
是的，长官。
All right. I assume you knew that it was not legal to vote other people's ballots.
好的。我假设你知道为别人投票是不合法的。
Right. We were doing what we were paid to do.
是的。我们是在做我们被付钱做的事。
I understand you, but you were paid to do something that you knew was wrong.
我理解你，但你被付钱做了一些你知道是错误的事情。
Yes, sir.
是的，长官。
The question on all this, of course, was, did the candidate, Mark Harris, know McCrae was directing all this fraudulent voting activity? Had Harris signed off on it? When Mark Harris finally took the stand, he was like, nope, not me. No idea any of this was going on, and I had no reason to doubt McCrae or what he was doing at the time.
关于这一切的问题当然是，候选人马克·哈里斯知道麦克雷在指导所有这些欺诈性投票活动吗？哈里斯批准了吗？当马克·哈里斯终于走上证人席时，他表现得像：不，不是我。我根本不知道正在发生这些事，而且我当时没有理由怀疑麦克雷或他正在做的事情。
The big moment in the hearing came on day three, when a surprise blockbuster witness upended the Harris team's narrative of things. That witness? His son. John Harris is a lawyer, at the time, an assistant US district attorney, respected, known lawyer in Raleigh.
听证会上的重大时刻出现在第三天，当时一位惊喜的重磅证人颠覆了哈里斯团队的叙述。那个证人是谁？他的儿子。约翰·哈里斯是一名律师，当时是助理美国联邦检察官，在罗利备受尊敬、知名的律师。
And John got up there, all fresh-faced at 29 years old, and was like, Dad, you knew. You knew McCrae was a fraudster, allegedly, and you knew because I told you. We talked about it. I sent you emails, emails which are now in possession of the court, showing you he'd likely cheated in elections before using absentee ballots. I warned you he was probably cheating now, and you ignored me. He recounted those emails and calls to his parents on the stand.
约翰站在那里，29岁，一脸稚气，他说：爸爸，你是知道的。你知道麦克雷被指控是个骗子，你知道是因为我告诉过你。我们谈论过它。我给你发过电子邮件，法院现在掌握着这些邮件，显示他在以前的选举中很可能利用缺席选票作弊。我警告过你他现在可能在作弊，而你忽视了我。他在证人席上讲述了那些发给父母的邮件和电话。
They believed McCrae when he said ballot collection doesn't take place. That's what he told them. I said, I don't believe McCrae because I've looked at the data, and the numbers don't add up. And I said, in the phone call, collecting a ballot is a felony, and I'll send you the statute.
他们相信麦克雷说没有发生选票收集的情况。那就是他告诉他们的。我说，我不相信麦克雷，因为我查看过数据，数字对不上。我在电话里说，收集选票是重罪，我会把法规发给你。
At the very end of his testimony, which the entire room seems to find extremely convincing, John Harris asked to make a statement. His voice cracks.
在他证词的最末尾，全场似乎都觉得非常令人信服，约翰·哈里斯要求发表声明。他的声音颤抖了。
I love my dad. I love my mom. OK? I certainly have no vendetta against them. I think that they made mistakes in this process.
我爱我的爸爸。我爱我的妈妈。好吗？我绝对没有针对他们的仇恨。我认为他们在这个过程中犯了错误。
John's crying. And then pan the camera to his dad, the candidate, Mark Harris. There's this famous picture of this moment. Mark Harris is crying, watching his son testify. You could see this as a moment where the reality of the situation finally caught up to Mark Harris, both Harris faces crumpling up with tears.
约翰哭了。然后摄像机转向他的父亲，候选人马克·哈里斯。关于这一刻有一张著名的照片。马克·哈里斯正在哭，看着儿子作证。你可以把这看作是一个现实终于赶上马克·哈里斯的时刻，两位哈里斯的脸上都挂满了泪水。
Was Mark Harris mad? Ashamed? Moved? He squirmed through hours of testimony the next day. And after a break, he walked into the hearing room tight-lipped and miserable. He looked down and read a statement off a piece of paper, admitting, yeah, some very bad things were done by his own campaign.
马克·哈里斯生气了吗？羞愧吗？感动吗？第二天他在几个小时的证词中如坐针毡。休息后，他紧闭双唇，痛苦地走进听证室。他低着头，照着一张纸念了一份声明，承认：是的，他自己的竞选团队做了一些非常糟糕的事情。
Neither I nor any of the leadership of my campaign were aware of or condoned the improper activities that had been testified to in this hearing. Through the testimony I've listened to over the past three days, I believe a new election should be called. It's become clear to me that the public's confidence in the 9th District seat general election has been undermined to an extent that a new election is warranted. Mr. Chairman, that concludes my statement.
无论是我还是我竞选团队的任何领导层，都不知道或纵容了听证会上作证的不当活动。通过我过去三天听到的证词，我认为应该要求重新选举。对我来说，很明显公众对第九选区席位大选的信心已经受到了损害，以至于有必要进行新的选举。主席先生，我的声明结束了。
Another moment of catching up to reality, I think-- Mark Harris essentially admitting, after everything we've heard, I agree with you guys. It was improper. Whether I should have known or not, my side screwed up so bad that, yeah, let's do it over.
我认为这是另一个赶上现实的时刻——马克·哈里斯基本上承认了，听了这一切后，我同意你们的观点。这是不当的。无论我是否应该知道，我这一边搞得太糟了，所以，是的，让我们重来一次吧。
After that, Mark Harris leaves immediately. And the hearing is pretty much over. The elections board unanimously votes to run a new election, and Harris doesn't run. Kind of a big deal. It was the first and only federal election to be overturned due to election fraud in 90 years.
之后，马克·哈里斯立即离开。听证会差不多就结束了。选举委员会一致投票决定进行新的选举，而哈里斯没有参加。这是一件大事。这是90年来唯一因选举舞弊而被推翻的联邦选举。
Anyway, that's where this tale of Mark Harris's short run for Congress lived in my mind-- a politician who had to admit the truth, sort of. So, imagine my surprise. Imagine how shocked, shocked, I was to see Mark Harris announce a run for Congress last year--
总之，这就是关于马克·哈里斯短暂竞选国会议员的故事在我脑海里的样子——一个被迫承认真相的政治家，某种程度上。所以，想象一下我的惊讶。想象一下我有多震惊，我是多么震惊地看到马克·哈里斯去年宣布参加国会议员竞选——
In 2020, Democrats stole the election from President Trump. The year before, they did it to me. Well, in 2024, President Trump is making a comeback, and so am I.
2020年，民主党人从特朗普总统手中偷走了选举。前一年，他们对我做了同样的事。嗯，在2024年，特朗普总统正在卷土重来，我也是。
--with a completely different version of what had happened in the 2018 election, a new version that matches exactly what former President Trump says about his election.
——对2018年选举发生的事情有着完全不同的版本，一个与前总统特朗普关于他自己的选举所说完全一致的新版本。
Just like the DOJ has come after Trump, the weaponized Democrat-controlled State Board of Elections came after me. They made up accusations, spread lies, and used the attention to make themselves famous. It didn't take long for the media machine to get in line with their attacks. And the onslaught raged. In the end, they succeeded. They stole the election and drug me through the mud.
就像司法部针对特朗普一样，武器化的民主党控制的州选举委员会也针对我。他们捏造指控，散布谎言，利用关注度让自己出名。没花多久媒体机器就站在了他们的攻击一边。猛烈抨击接踵而至。最终，他们成功了。他们偷走了选举，把我拖进了泥潭。
First of all, where do I start? Dr. Mark Harris, you were the one who called for a new election back then. Remember? I understand that running a campaign based on being persecuted is very en vogue right now, but this is a very extreme example of it-- Harris claiming he was persecuted for something that he himself was accused of, election fraud, allegedly engineered by the campaign guy he hired.
首先，我从哪开始呢？马克·哈里斯博士，当时是你要求重新选举的。还记得吗？我理解以受迫害为基础进行竞选现在非常流行，但这确实是一个非常极端的例子——哈里斯声称他因自己被指控的事情而受到迫害，即选举舞弊，据称是由他雇佣的竞选人员策划的。
But Mark Harris is reading the room correctly. This is the new reality we all live in. Saying you had an election stolen from you-- people like that, even, and maybe especially even, if it isn't actually true.
但马克·哈里斯确实读懂了房间里的气氛。这就是我们所有人都生活在其中的新现实。说你的选举被偷走了——人们喜欢那种说法，即使，或者特别是在它不是真的情况下。
I reached out to Harris and his son to discuss this new take on things. Neither one would talk to me. This wonderful TV reporter in North Carolina, though, Joe Bruno, asked Harris about this a few weeks ago.
我联系了哈里斯和他的儿子来讨论这种对事情的新看法。他们俩都不跟我说话。不过，北卡罗来纳州的一位出色的电视记者乔·布鲁诺几周前问过哈里斯这个问题。
People testified under oath. 11 people were criminally charged. Six pleaded guilty. Four still have pending charges. And you yourself said that public confidence was undermined in the election on the stand. So how can you call it a manufactured scandal?
人们在宣誓后作证。11人被刑事起诉。6人认罪。4人仍有待决指控。而你自己也在证人席上说公众对选举的信心受到了损害。那你怎么能称之为制造出来的丑闻？
Well, I think when you really look at the facts that ended up coming out later, there were things not shared. It's almost like there was information that was not shared in the hearing.
嗯，我认为当你真正审视后来得出的事实时，有些事情没有被分享。几乎就像听证会中有一些信息没有被披露一样。
That's its own move right there. The "everything hasn't come out" move, the "once it does, I will be vindicated" move.
这就是那里的一个动作。那种“一切还没水落石出”的动作，那种“一旦水落石出，我就会被证明清白”的动作。
Do you accept that your race in 2018 was tainted to the point where a new election was necessary?
你接受你在2018年的竞选受到了玷污，以至于有必要重新选举吗？
No. I don't think there should have been a new election based on all of what happened.
不。我不认为基于所发生的一切，应该进行新的选举。
I'll say again, he's the one who called for that new election back then. There's reality, and then there's political reality. The two of them are so far apart right now. Post-2020, Republican politicians are pretty much required to agree that the election was stolen from Donald Trump. I think that's just the table stakes.
我再说一遍，当初要求重新选举的人就是他。有现实，也有政治现实。它们现在离得太远了。2020年后，共和党政治家几乎必须同意特朗普的选举被偷走了。我认为这只是门槛。
Mark Harris and a bunch of other candidates are taking it one step further and saying it happened to me, too. I have personally felt the pain of a stolen election. And it works. Last week, on Super Tuesday, Mark Harris won the primary. In this district, that means he finally gets to go to Congress. Welcome to Washington, Dr. Harris.
马克·哈里斯和其他许多候选人更进一步，说这也发生在我身上。我亲身感受到了选举被偷走的痛苦。而且它奏效了。上周，在“超级星期二”，马克·哈里斯赢得了初选。在这个选区，这意味着他终于可以进入国会了。欢迎来到华盛顿，哈里斯博士。
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our program. Her podcast where she tells the whole story about how election fraud accusations tore apart Bladen County. If you have not heard this, it's called The Improvement Association. It's from Serial Productions and the New York Times.
佐伊·切斯是我们节目的制片人之一。她的播客讲述了选举舞弊指控如何撕裂布雷登县的完整故事。如果你没听过，它叫《改进协会》。它来自Serial Productions和《纽约时报》。
Act Four, What'd I Miss? So we close our show today with this story from Tobin Low about a very special group of people who have to catch up to new realities all the time. They have no choice. It's part of their lives. Here's Tobin.
第四幕，我错过了什么？所以我们今天以托宾·洛的这个故事结束我们的节目，关于一群非常特别的人，他们必须一直赶上新的现实。他们别无选择。这是他们生活的一部分。托宾请讲。
This specific morning was unremarkable. Joe Dombrowski, a public school teacher at the time, was getting ready for work. He'd been out for a while, so he wanted to get to school a little early to get back in the swing of things. He ate a quick breakfast, dashed out the door.
这个特定的早晨平淡无奇。当时是公立学校老师的乔·东布罗夫斯基正准备去上班。他已经请假一段时间了，所以想早点到学校，重新回到工作节奏。他吃了个简易早餐，冲出门。
Everything's pretty normal as I'm getting there. I'm driving through the suburbs. Everything's looking great. And I really noticed at the moment I got on the highway, there was absolutely no line to merge onto the highway at all.
当我到达时，一切都很正常。我开车穿过郊区。一切看起来都很棒。当我上了高速公路时，我确实注意到，合并进高速公路的地方完全没有排队。
And is there usually a line to merge on the highway?
通常合并进高速公路有车队吗？
Detroit is the city of cars, right? So we're no stranger to traffic. But as I was driving and realizing just how few cars were on the road, I started thinking, when did this area of town become this ghost town?
底特律是汽车之城，对吧？所以我们对交通并不陌生。但当我开车时，意识到路上几乎没有车，我开始想，这个地区的这段路什么时候变成了鬼城？
He arrives at school, walks down a small flight of stairs to the front desk, where the school secretary and the principal are hanging out.
他到达学校，走下几级台阶来到前台，秘书和校长在那里闲聊。
And when I turned the corner, when they both looked at me, I could see a sense of panic in their eyes. And at first, I was like, they're surprised to see me. But then it sort of switched. I could see legitimate concern in their faces.
当我转过弯，当他们俩看着我时，我能看到他们眼中的恐慌。起初，我还以为他们是惊讶看到我。但随后情况发生了转变。我能在他们脸上看到真诚的担心。
The secretary stood up, turned around the corner to speak to me. They're like both immediately wanted to know, how did you get here? How did you get here? What roads did you take? Tell us. And I was like, I did this, this, and this. And they were just like, oh, my God. There's a sniper on this road. You could have been killed.
秘书站起来，转过弯来跟我说话。他们俩立刻想知道：你是怎么到这儿的？你是怎么来的？你走的是哪条路？告诉我们。我说，我走了这条，这条，还有这条。他们只是说，天哪。那条路上有个狙击手。你可能会被杀的。
Apparently, a man with a gun had been randomly firing at people along I-96 that week, the very highway Joe had just taken to work. The man would end up shooting at 23 drivers.
显然，一个拿着枪的人那周一直在I-96沿线随机向人们开枪，那正是乔刚走的那条高速公路。那个人最终向23名司机开枪。
After speaking with them, this was a thing that quickly became known to me that everybody was well aware of in the area. It was kind of like, I had been sleeping for a couple of weeks and missed everything. And now I'm just getting caught up to speed.
在和他们谈过之后，我很快就知道了这个情况，该地区每个人都非常清楚。这就好比，我像睡了几个星期，错过了所有事情。现在我只是刚跟上节奏。
It wasn't even kind of like that. That's literally what happened. He had been asleep for the past three weeks and missed everything. And I don't mean napping or catching up on rest. Joe has a rare neurological disorder called Kleine-Levin Syndrome, or KLS. It affects about 1 in a million people. And its defining feature is that those who have it experience episodes of extreme exhaustion, entering a deep sleep for days, weeks, or even months at a time.
甚至都不像那样。这真的是所发生的事情。他过去三周一直在睡觉，错过了所有事情。我指的不是打盹或补觉。乔有一种罕见的神经系统疾病，叫“克莱恩-莱文综合征”，简称KLS。它影响大约一百万人中的一人。其定义的特征是患者会经历极度疲劳的发作，陷入深度睡眠，持续几天、几周甚至几个月。
Now and then, they wake up. But when they do, they're in a fog, usually with only enough energy to eat a little, use the bathroom, and then back to bed. There's no known cause for KLS and also no known cure. When Joe first started showing symptoms as a teenager, it was completely debilitating. He'd go to school, feeling like he'd just pulled all-nighters for three weeks in a row.
偶尔，他们会醒来。但当他们醒来时，身处雾中，通常只有足够的精力吃点东西、上厕所，然后就又回去睡觉。KLS没有已知的病因，也没有已知的治疗方法。乔十几岁第一次出现症状时，完全使人衰弱。他去学校时，感觉就像连续三周没睡觉一样。
There's nothing keeping you awake. You feel it and you're done. I remember I would walk from class to class, and the minute I would hit my seat, I would sleep. Done, head on the table, sleeping. Teachers yelling at me, trying to get me to wake back up, pulling me out of class, giving me detention for sleeping in class, calling, telling my parents he's sleeping. All he does is sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep.
没有什么能让你保持清醒。你感觉到它，你就完了。记得我会从一个教室走到另一个教室，我一坐到座位上，就会睡着。完了，头靠在桌子上睡觉。老师对我大喊大叫，试图让我醒过来，把我从教室里拽出来，因为在课上睡觉给我留校察看，打电话告诉我父母：他在睡觉。他所做的就是睡觉，睡，睡，睡，睡。
When he finally got a diagnosis, he learned that the only way out of an episode was to give in to it, which is what people with KLS have to do. They just have to sleep for however long it takes to get past it. So people with KLS frequently find themselves emerging into a very different reality than the one they left.
当他最终得到诊断时，他了解到摆脱发作的唯一方法就是顺从它，这就是KLS患者必须做的。他们必须睡到过去为止，无论需要多久。所以KLS患者经常发现自己进入了一个与离开时截然不同的现实。
I talked to someone who missed the onset of COVID completely, woke up to a shutdown world. I talked to another guy who missed the events of 9/11 and a woman in Ecuador who recently woke up to find out war had broken out in her country. But the person I talked to who experienced the longest episodes by far was Arielle Poleg.
我采访了一个完全错过新冠爆发的人，醒来时世界已经封锁了。我采访了另一个人，他错过了9/11事件，还有一位厄瓜多尔的女士，最近醒来时发现她的国家爆发了战争。但采访过的人中，经历最长发作的人是阿丽尔·波莱格。
I had a nine-month episode and a 15-month episode.
我有过一次九个月的发作和一次15个月的发作。
15 months, wow.
15个月，哇。
Yeah. So, when I was 25 and 26, I was sick for over a year.
是的。所以，我25岁和26岁时，病了超过一年。
During that year, Arielle had to put off her plans to go to grad school and instead, move into her childhood bedroom at her parents' house in Boston.
那一年，阿丽尔不得不推迟读研计划，搬进波士顿父母家她童年的卧室里。
I didn't go downstairs in my parents' home for that entire 15 months. I did go to the bathroom on the upstairs floor. My bedroom's upstairs. But I didn't go downstairs the whole time. I did not see anybody or speak to anybody.
在那15个月里，我没下过楼。我确实去了楼上的洗手间。我的卧室在楼上。但我整个时间都没下楼。我没见到任何人，也没跟任何人说话。
It was 2005. I pulled up some of the biggest headlines from that year, just to get a sense of how much you could miss in that amount of time. She slept through the death of Pope John Paul II, Hurricane Katrina. She remembers seeing some headlines about it in magazines her mom left for her, but not much more than that.
那是2005年。我查了那一年的几个头条新闻，只是想感受一下在那段时间你会错过多少事情。她睡过了教皇约翰·保罗二世的去世、卡特里娜飓风。她记得看到她妈妈留给她的杂志上有一些关于飓风的头条，但仅此而已。
Star Wars, Episode III, Revenge of the Sith was the top grossing movie of that year.
《星球大战前传III：西斯的复仇》是那一年的票房冠军。
No, but that would not have meant anything to me anyway.
不，不过这对我也没什么意义。
I guess 2005 was also the year Tom Cruise jumped on Oprah's couch.
我想2005年也是汤姆·克鲁斯在奥普拉的沙发上跳跃的一年。
I remember reading about that after. I was not at all aware or present when that happened.
我记得后来读到过那个。那发生时我完全不知道，也不在场。
During those 15 months, all she knew was that she'd sleep almost all day and night, wake up for some amount of time, and then go back to sleep. And even during those waking hours, she'd be in a haze. She wouldn't talk. The people I talked to described waking up during an episode as extremely confusing and disorienting, like they couldn't tell what was real or what they were hallucinating.
在那15个月里，她只知道自己几乎整天整夜都在睡觉，醒来一段时间，然后又去睡觉。即使在那些醒着的时刻，她也处于迷茫中。她不说话。我采访的人形容在发作期间醒来非常令人困惑和迷惑，就像他们分不清什么是真实的，什么是幻觉。
During the episode, I was somewhat aware of the passage of time, but also somewhat not.
发作期间，我多少意识到时间的流逝，但某种程度上也没意识到。
The challenge was really the longevity. This is so long, as she had gone through all these different-- this long period of time. And we would try to give her a sense of the seasons changing.
挑战真的在于长期性。这太漫长了，因为她经历了所有这些不同的——这段漫长的时间。我们会试着让她感知季节的变换。
This is Arielle's dad, Neal. Arielle had gone into her episode in July.
这是阿丽尔的父亲，尼尔。阿丽尔七月份开始发作。
So, at one point, it was snowing outside. So I went outside and just took a cup of-- a paper cup and brought some snow inside. And I just remember she looked at it. She felt it, and there was a sense of, oh, my God, this is snow.
所以，有一次外面在下雪。我就出去拿了一个杯子——一个纸杯，带了一些雪进来。我只记得她看着它。她摸了它，有一种“天哪，这是雪”的感觉。
I remember just looking at him and tears leaking. I didn't say anything. I couldn't say anything. But I felt very sad to see the snow.
我记得只是看着他，泪水渗出。我什么也没说。我没法说什么。但我看到雪感到非常难过。
Yeah, it was incredulous that she had been in bed all that time. And there's a disbelief that all this is happening, because the last thing she had remembered, it was nice weather.
是的，她在那儿待了那么久，这让人难以置信。而且人们不相信这一切正在发生，因为她记得的最后一件事还是天气很好。
Arielle says even though she missed a whole year of her life, that's not the episode that sticks out to her. The one that really hurt happened when she was a teenager. She was in a deep sleep for a couple of weeks, but occasionally, when she would get up to use the restroom, she'd see her dad in the hallway.
阿丽尔说，即使她错过了一整年的人生，那也不是让她感触最深的一次发作。真正伤害她的是她十几岁时那次。她深睡了几周，但偶尔去洗手间时，她会看到走廊里的爸爸。
So my father wasn't shaving. And I saw him, and I saw that he was growing a beard. That was confusing, layered on to the confusion of having KLS, and then, all of a sudden, my dad looked different. And I wasn't quite sure why.
所以我爸爸没刮胡子。我看见他，我看见他在留胡子。这很令人困惑，叠加在患有KLS的困惑之上，然后突然之间，我爸爸看起来不同了。我不太确定原因。
When she did finally come out of it, she found out her grandfather had gotten sick and died. That's why her dad hadn't shaved. He was observing a Jewish tradition when you're in mourning. She looked at pictures of the rest of her family, who had been able to travel to see her grandfather to say their last words to him.
当她最终醒来时，她发现她的祖父病重去世了。这就是她爸爸没刮胡子的原因。他在遵守犹太人的哀悼传统。她看着家里其他人的照片，他们能够去探望祖父，对他说了临终遗言。
That was the first time something like that happened, like something that I couldn't get back. I always was a good student and able to make up work at school and able to make up things that I had missed, but you can't get back the opportunity to say goodbye to someone. So that was different.
那是第一次发生这种事，像我无法挽回的事情。我一直是个好学生，能补上学校的功课，能补上错过的东西，但你无法补上跟某人告别的机会。所以那次不同。
It makes me think about my grandmother who passed away several years ago. She had a stroke and her passing was this really long process. It just took a very long time. And I remember, at times, feeling like I wish I could skip this part. Like, I wish I could zoom forward to what's eventually going to happen.
这让我想起几年前去世的祖母。她中风了，她的离世是一个漫长的过程。这真的花了很多时间。我记得有时会感觉我想跳过这一部分。就像我想快进到最终会发生的事情一样。
In my case, my experience of being robbed of those chances to be present made me prefer to be present, to adjust to a changing reality, right? To process the information in real-time as it was happening. I think as somebody who missed a lot of moments, I would always prefer to experience a moment, even if it's painful.
在我的案例中，被剥夺了出席机会的经历让我更喜欢出席，去适应变化的现实，对吧？去实时处理正在发生的信息。我认为作为一个错过很多时刻的人，我总是宁愿去经历一个时刻，即使它是痛苦的。
I see that. Before talking to Arielle, I don't know that I would have said I'm glad I was there for the most difficult parts of my grandmother's decline, but now I get it. It's way worse to have a new reality hit you all at once. Better to be there. Lucky, even.
我明白了。在采访阿丽尔之前，我不知道我会不会说我很高兴我在祖母衰退最困难的时候陪在她身边，但现在我明白了。突然被一个新现实击中要糟糕得多。最好身处其中。甚至可以说是幸运。
Tobin Low is an editor here at our program. If you think you might have the often misdiagnosed Kleine-Levin Syndrome, you can get more information from the KLS Foundation at klsfoundation.org.
托宾·洛是我们节目的编辑。如果你认为你可能患有常被误诊的“克莱恩-莱文综合征”，你可以从KLS基金会获取更多信息，网址是klsfoundation.org。
Well, our program was produced today by Diane Wu and Bethel Habte. The people who put our show together include Phia Bennin, Jendayi Bonds, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Chana Joffe-Walt, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Safiyah Riddle, Ryan Rumery, Laura Starecheski, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
嗯，我们的节目今天由黛安·吴和贝瑟尔·哈布特制作。整理我们节目的成员包括菲亚·本宁、詹达伊·邦兹、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、萨菲亚·里德尔、莱恩·鲁默里、劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基、莉莉·沙利文、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。我们的主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to Isaac Arnsdorf, Josh Lawson, Ben Phelan, Julie Snyder, Neil Drumming, Daniela Villarreal, Emmanuel Mignot, Varda Poleg, Kelsey Padgett, and Catherine Scott.
今天特别感谢艾萨克·阿恩斯多夫、乔什·劳森、本·费伦、朱莉·斯奈德、尼尔·德拉明、丹妮拉·比利亚雷亚尔、伊曼纽尔·米诺特、瓦尔达·波莱格、凯尔西·帕吉特和凯瑟琳·斯科特。
Thanks also today to Alex Steffen. The quote from him that we named this week's show after was in a story by Elizabeth Weil for The New York Times Magazine called "This Isn't the California I Married." Jackson Landers, the guy who got bit by the black spider, also wrote about his experience for The New York Times. His book about hunting invasive species is called Eating Aliens.
也感谢亚历克斯·史蒂芬。我们这一周节目名称所引用的他的名言出自伊丽莎白·韦尔为《纽约时报杂志》撰写的一篇故事，标题是《这不是我嫁的加利福尼亚》。被黑寡妇咬伤的杰克逊·兰德斯也为《纽约时报》写过他的经历。他关于猎捕入侵物种的书叫《吃掉外星人》。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can listen to over 800 episodes of our show for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. They tried to make him go to rehab, and he said--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。你可以免费收听我们节目800多集的内容。《美国生活》由公共广播交换机构PRX传送给各公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他们试图让他去戒毒，他说——
No, no, no.
不，不，不。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。